ross how are you doing
i'm good how are you i'm doing wrong
time i know how how things been going it
seems like uh a lot of things that you
were excited about uh maybe a year ago
or so they're all uh playing out pretty
nicely there my friend
yeah you know so far so good you know we
we're having a little uh interlude as
the fed you know gets its act together
this year but you know we we like the
opportunity in the markets right now and
we're seeing some nice fear and i like
it let's talk fed first because i think
that's kind of what's on everyone's mind
we're recording this uh the day of the
fomc uh meeting we're expecting them to
go ahead and announce a 50 basis point
hike uh it seems like you know on the
last two years don't fight the fed
they're pushing everything up just get
long and chill now they're intentionally
pushing things down um and so maybe you
don't want to be as long as you as you
previously were is that the trade of the
decade is just whatever the fed tells
you to do do it and then you win
it's pretty much the trade of the last
three decades really my whole career
you know there's only one person that's
ever killed the economy and that's the
federal reserve chairman
and you know even greenspan did it and
and you know actually powell did it in
18 you think he would have learned his
lesson in 18.
um but right now we went from a stage
you know if you look at it from
the pandemic was probably the worst
economic event in american history we
shut down the entire economy and and we
made up for it by printing tons of money
and having you know just a free-for-all
at the fed
and now you know it's worked and things
are really good in the economy and the
fed has to just like get back to normal
and people look at that as like the end
of the world when it's actually what's
supposed to happen so
so valuations come back to normal i i
don't see this as any crazy thing so you
just gotta like kind of wait until the
fed's done with their game and then
we're game on again you know what what
do you think they're gonna end up doing
so uh the market's pricing in 50 basis
points today
2.75 to 3 by the end of the year do you
think they can hike that much or do you
see them stopping at some point maybe
there's even will there be a fed
interest rate cut before the end of the
year how do you think about this
well that would be
the classic fed you know you see that a
lot with the fed where they raise too
fast and then they're like oh and then
they do this like one cut just to make
the market happy and get the economy
going again that's actually not uncommon
um
that's what i think that's what i think
they're going to do by the way that
that's my best it's not uncommon yeah
you know like that wouldn't surprise me
at all because what i actually think is
you know you have this pandemic you know
stimulus response thing where now
everybody's partying like crazy and
going out like crazy and you know trying
to go to europe this summer is
impossible and you know every event is
sold out from coachella uh to the met
gala or whatever and so when you when
you look at what people are doing
they're out and they're spending money
and that'll calm down you know in six
months or a year as people like go back
to normal and and sort of get it out of
their system but i still think
you know that it'll take a while and
people have jobs and they're getting
raises and they're spending money so
this is a really good backdrop for the
fed to raise interest rates into the the
bottom line is they're behind the curve
and that's why i'm not so concerned
about them
right now is is i think one and a half
to two is probably where they need to be
right now you know and so they're not
there so they got to catch up to one and
a half to two but once i think they get
to one and a half to two they're gonna
have to really reassess where the
economy really is because high oil
prices and high inflation does
affect spending eventually and and
people will spend less and
and so i think
um as we get towards the elections we'll
see the economy slow and inflation come
down and i think the fed will have less
pressure on them to be aggressive yeah
one of the things that i keep going to
is if we already had the you know kind
of annualized 1.4 contraction in q1 uh
if they continue to hike the interest
rates they push us more towards uh not
just a slowdown in the economy but a
full-on recession and you know i joke
all the time like what's worse than high
inflation for a politician going into an
election is a recession and so if we get
to uh a true recession where people are
feeling it and it's very obvious that
it's here uh regardless of what's
happening with inflation i think that
the federal just get pressured right
it's just hate yeah i just don't think
that's a reality this year you know like
i don't think
the fed can hike fast enough unless
they're just crazy to cause a recession
this year what i'm worried about is like
the beginning middle of next year where
it's like all this stuff finally
compounds up we get through christmas
and and travel and and and maybe there's
another surge of some sort and then we
look into you know the first half of
next year looks real bad but but i
actually don't think that's going to
happen either i
i think the fed will do everything
possible to avoid creating recession
they they will lower rates they will
print money they will do anything they
need to do to prevent a recession so i
i'm not that concerned about it because
the demand is so high for labor right
now yeah when you start thinking about
various assets in the market obviously
stocks i think uh people understand hey
when when the feds got the money printer
on they go up when they stop uh they go
down and that seems to be what uh most
people are are experiencing at the
moment when you're talking to clients
like how do you talk about uh these
types of environments is it a thing of
like hey just try to get into cash and
just hold cash is it you know actually
buy the dips or like what's kind of the
general talk track
well
we're typically managing stocks and
bonds for clients so
you know when this all started with the
inflation stuff and the fed a few months
back i sold all of them you know sold
all my bonds pretty much
um
i'm much more concerned about bonds than
stocks because stocks actually do okay
in inflation because you get higher
pricing you know um it's it's bonds that
just have like negative value
you know so all of a sudden
if you're buying a two or even a three
percent you know treasury bond you're
losing a lot of money right now
so that makes no sense to me at all like
and then there's no upside right like
what's your upside in a bond today it's
negative right so
so bonds are really where the highest
risk is because you have no real upside
and you have lots of potential downside
so we immediately moved to more cash so
we're holding like more cash than i
really like by a large amount
right now because we just don't really
have much of a bond allocation so we're
looking at inflation-protected
treasuries and floating rates are really
the only game in town and then these
like high yields like you know amc bonds
are paying 14 still so you know stuff
like that
so you hold a lot of cash and
and then on the equity side
what we have is actually equities are in
a way fine it's just we're having pe
contraction and pe contraction obviously
hurts growth names like that i typically
like more than it you know affects
campbell's soup and you know chevron so
because we don't own campbell's soup and
chevron we're underperforming
substantially right now
and we know this you know like because
we're not going to start buying campbell
soup and chevron because these are just
temporary shifts
in the market as we have this rising
interest rate environment
um and rising inflation environment
and so
you just have to be patient you know
like i've done this for so long and and
you want to buy and trade and you want
to make money on the upside and it's
just not going to happen right now you
know yeah and when you start to think
about this so let's go to so that's what
i tell clients you just have to be
patient you know like they want to make
money every year i make 15 a year for
these people in a 60 40 portfolio and
then we finally have a bad year and
they're like oh my god and i'm like dude
look at the last five years you know
we've averaged 15 a year including this
year right now i'm like we were way
above trend line like what did you think
it happened so you know most of my
clients been around you know i've been
doing this almost 30 years so so it
happens every cycle you get the rising
interest rate period of time you got to
sit on your hands yeah when you think
about some of those growth stocks i
think tesla's probably one of the the
biggest ones one of the most popular
ones i know that you're a huge fan of
elon
and of tesla talk to me a little bit
about what uh what you think about kind
of that business and and uh maybe
headwinds or tailwinds that it has
well tesla i would say is the exception
to all the things i was just saying
because they're executing so well and
the environment for tesla couldn't be
better with you know gas six dollars a
gallon here in l.a all you see are
tesla's like everywhere now you know so
like you're almost like an idiot if you
go out and like i saw somebody just
bought a new explorer in my parking lot
and i'm like you must be like an idiot
you know it's like you're gonna pay six
dollars a gallon for 15 miles a gallon
in traffic or 10 miles a gallon in
traffic in la i'm like you're spending
150 a week just driving your kids around
baseball and stuff and i'm like i spend
nothing
you know i'm like if you don't like
inflation you go buy an ev it's simple
as that and so people are and so the
demand is far outstripping the supply
and the real game is supply can we make
cars and and with china that's just been
a huge problem so china is the biggest
problem for the global economy right now
it makes interest rates seem like
nothing
honestly like i don't even spend any
time worrying about the fed i'm worried
about china because we make a lot of
stuff in china we make cars in china we
make phones in china we make half the
stuff i own makes stuff in china you
know and china is like
whack-a-mole with
kovid which is definitely a losing game
and you know it's a mess it's just a
mess so it's hard for tesla to
manufacture right now in china which is
their best market to sell and
manufacture and we have new plants that
are coming up in austin and in berlin
but we're you know 12 months from
efficient you know production
and so it's a really great time for
tesla right now but but this is a super
challenging time as well yeah it makes
that makes a lot of sense obviously elon
uh has done a fantastic job building
that business uh he now has he's turning
his uh his attention to twitter uh he a
couple of things here so like one just
like what's your general read on the
whole twitter situation are you a fan of
elon doing this do you think it's a
distraction how do you read it uh to
start well i'm going to tell you some
things pomp you know a lot of there's a
lot of misinformation going around about
this whole twitter thing
and i just read in the paper that the
head of the cia flew out to saudi arabia
last month
and i think it was to tell them that we
were taking twitter back from them
and that's what this is really about
whether people want to
you know
worry about donald trump being on the
platform oh no god forbid you know the
right wing
might have free speech or or this or
that what it's really about is foreign
interference in our elections in our
democracy it's gotten to a
horrible situation in america and in
western governments now with the war in
ukraine it's become so obvious the
misinformation
um that's put out on twitter daily the
constant attacks the bots um it became a
national security issue for the united
states became a major issue for um tesla
because tesla uses twitter as its main
advertising vehicle and elon felt it was
time to step in and take this asset back
from the foreign actors that have been
manipulating it so a couple of questions
first is uh you think saudi arabia owns
twitter or like like what was that they
do own twitter they own six percent of
twitter but i think they control twitter
internally
and in what way like do you think it's
part of like the content moderation
decisions do you think that they've got
some sort of leverage over the executive
team like tell me more about that
i think they've implanted people in
executives from all the way through the
company that are acting to
uh help with the misinformation
campaigns that have been so effective on
social media saudi arabia and russia
being the two biggest beneficiaries of
these misinformation campaigns um we
have a very insidious
thing going on in social media and with
instagram and facebook we have no
ability to get control of these assets
because zuckerberg controls it like the
great overlord of misinformation
um and we're seeing it in countries like
india where modi has used it to oppress
uh people and really
fervent nationalism against the muslim
pop population in india and and it
creates violence and and you know
oppression essentially so zuckerberg and
sandberg are perfectly fine with all of
it as long as they make money um and i
think
people like elon had had enough of this
stuff so so you know now
he's stepping in and using his
considerable financial might to do
something i think that's going to be a
benefit to our society and very
profitable for ultimately twitter
shareholders so he my understanding is
he's basically putting up some of his
tesla shares as collateral uh and then
also getting a you know a bunch of
financing and kind of putting together
what is going to end up being a somewhat
complex deal uh as a tesla shareholder
do you worry about the tesla shares
being uh collateralized to help finance
the uh the acquisition of twitter
no
what what do you like like how do you
say it's a 20 it's like a 25 margin
position so it's not like he's highly
leveraged in it and quite frankly i
think the tesla shares
are the most valuable shares in the
stock market so you know
i i don't really spend much time
worrying about that either because
you know
like when elon sold shares last week it
was like to a benefit of the public
because he's not like not operating
tesla he went from owning 17 percent of
tesla to 16 of tesla and it pushes the
price down and allows other investors to
buy tesla stock at a cheaper price when
we all know the information that's out
there that tesla is executing
brilliantly right now in a product
that's in such high demand that they
really just can't supply it and um what
i i'm seeing from yesterday is it looks
and this is what's going to happen next
so so maybe this is the first place i'm
really saying this is that uh
tesla's prepared to build a second
gigafactory in texas and a second gig or
factory in shanghai and i expect formal
announcements for that fairly soon so
you think that they're going to build a
second gigafactory in texas and the
second one in shanghai uh along with the
plans that they've already publicly
announced
yeah why do you why do you think that
that is uh is the plan
because i thought about it last night
long enough
no you just did some thinking and you
just said hey if i was uh tesla is what
i would do
like i can't tell you everything you
know
like i uh
my sources of information
are deep
really deep i dig
i dig a deeper hole than anybody in my
business about the companies i own
and
the amount of people and information i
get about tesla there's nobody knows
more about tesla in the world than me
maybe a couple other investors but very
few
um
and
and that's what's going to happen next
okay so i surmise all the information
data points that i get and then i
perceive what the next strategic
decision my man mr musk is going to make
and i look at the reality of
the situations and
that's what's going to happen next are
you an elon boys like you guys text or
like hang out or anything
no no i i thought that i saw you guys
tweeting at each other on twitter or
something we tweet at each other all the
time all right you know because that's
that's in the digital world no not your
boys
like i went out to the cyber rodeo you
know like i i was like hanging out with
his mom and and kimball and
and and uh and his sister who's super
cool tosca and and you know we're in the
vip area with all the vips you know and
elon's like you know
twice the rock star i'll ever be you
know what i mean he's like
he's like people are like mobbing them
so i'm like i can't even talk to the guy
you know it's like i can't even you know
i'm not gonna push through a hundred
people to talk to him um
you know i i uh one day i'd i hope to to
get a beer with elon
you know yeah i i think that you could
probably uh figure out a way to get that
done talk to me yeah but it's like you
know part of it is like because i'm an
investor and i'm i'm in the media pretty
much every day about tesla
you know
i i don't i'm not access to information
like i don't have a separate
relationship with elon that could create
insider trading issues or concepts of
interest so in a way it's like good that
we don't have that relationship because
i would probably be accused of lots of
stuff if we did
even though it wouldn't be true so you
know i get all my information
you know the way i get my information
it's not directly from board members or
senior executives so
so you know and and that's you got to
play the game the right way you know i
play the game the fair way and i play it
the right way although i play it as
right as possible you know yeah so
that's where you get into potential
issues and and i do talk to a lot of
ceos i do
um and and i really am trying to
ascertain what type of people they are
um because it gets real you know
you don't want to end up like uh diane
von furstenberg and uh who is it it's
barry diller right now insider trading
you know they clearly were insider
trading with bobby cottick having lunch
with him and then buying 100 million in
options on activision right before it
gets bought out i mean come on so when
when you think about uh other stocks
tesla i think is the biggest position
that you guys have as an individual
stock what's the second biggest
right now it's mgm hotels all right
what's the theory or thesis behind mgm
hotels
so this is getting really good okay all
right so
i like good
like really good like
i really like this like there's
you know like there's technology
investments in bitcoin which obviously
the upside is just like crazy right and
then there's like real investments like
real estate or hotels or whatever you
know so technology always has the most
upside potential in my mind that's why
it's the largest percentage of assets
that we manage is in technology
investments and including bitcoin and
things like that um
so when you think about the economy
moving forward
fun is the most important thing right
now and so
um vegas is in a rebound like i've never
seen so there's been a lot of
adjustments to what's happening
in vegas over the last two years because
of coveted and many of the companies
including mgm
not only have begun building an online
gambling business but also we're in the
process of sort of reassessing their
their overall operations and the use of
technology within the hotel and gaming
space and because of covid they were
forced to implement large amounts of
innovation that normally hotel and
casino companies don't do
very rapidly you know and so
with this innovation they've been able
to increase margins into hotel
substantially like
really substantially because there are
so many inefficiencies in the way hotels
and casinos are run currently so
technology had an enormous
upside in this leisure and hospitality
area and mgm rapidly employed it
successfully the ceo is really really
good this guy hornbuckle and he's been
working at the company a long time knows
the business knows vegas
so what happened was mgm decided not to
own their buildings anymore just be an
operating company and sell off all the
buildings for cash and they've gotten
all this cash over the years and they've
been buying back stock and then like
like upgrading casinos and then making
trades so they just sold the mirage
casino and bought the cosmopolitan so
the cosmopolitan is the best uh hotel
casino in vegas for fun for young people
it's it's just an amazing asset so they
got that and they also took full control
of city center um which is arya and
vadara
and so they've gotten full control of
all these assets and and then they sold
off all the land and
you know sort of the buildings under it
and they just finished that with a deal
with vici properties where now mgm just
got 4.4 billion in new cash which they
paid off debt um doing these
transactions and now bought this
european online gambling company called
i think it's called that leo or
something like that or leo
something i don't know just bought it um
now they're expanding online gambling
now if you look at what's happening in
california for example they're trying to
pass online gambling here in california
the native american casinos have had
this monopoly on it and bet mgm and
draftkings and and fanduel are trying to
break this monopoly and and get open in
more states but right now i think they
have 21 states or so with online
gambling so they've got all this
convergence of the online with people
going out and the in the two areas for
mgm that are really tough are uh their
investments in macau which are basically
shut down so that's sort of like
sort of this upside once china comes
back maybe in a year and then you've got
um
um so so the macau thing is is kind of
the
dog of the company
um
but you've got this like
rapidly growing convention business and
i think because of work from home
companies are going to be spending more
and more money on getting together
employees and things like conventions in
vegas and then you've got
um really just an unbelievable amount of
spending as people are going out again
and we're seeing the average person
spend a huge amount of money
so then sports came to vegas you know
so
now we've got the raiders and in the
golden knights but what's happening next
is hopefully the oakland a's are going
to be moving to
vegas we we hope and we expect a nba
expansion franchise
uh as well in vegas and we've got the
uh super bowl in 24 and formula one at
the end of 23. so vegas has become this
like sports city and it's hugely
lucrative and complementary to the other
entertainment that already exists in
vegas
so i've never been more bullish on the
future of vegas than i am right now
so when you start to think about this uh
and you see a business like it do you
worry about the price at which you're
buying or do you worry about like
short-term price movements or do you
just look at the fundamentals and say
hey here is kind of our thesis on this
and we're going to hold this for a long
time so the price at which we buy it or
the short-term price fluctuations may
not matter no price matters for sure
you know during the pandemic we got into
mgm at nine bucks or something so that
was ideal and the only reason i bought
it was because i knew their cash
financial position because they had just
sold these casinos you know
and um and it was and it's been probably
i think it was one of the best stocks i
bought in the pandemic as far as returns
are concerned several hundred percent
but
at 40 bucks i don't think you know
because it's hard to value because it
really hasn't had earnings you know
since the pandemic and they're about
break even now
um
but what it is is what the assets are
worth and so when you like
add up the equity value of the business
it's trading at sort of this traditional
multiple like two times the equity which
is you know pretty normal for casinos
but the growth right now and the way
they change the business i think
it's undervalued by at least 20 percent
maybe 25
at the current price so we we value it
closer to 50 it's trading at 40 so i
like that and they're solid assets um
you know
vegas isn't going anywhere so the the
real boogeyman that i think is also
super bullish for mgm is this osaka
project in japan
you know japan's gonna have you know
gambling by the end of the century and
mgm is really in the lead for building
this thing and i they released like the
plans for this thing and it's amazing
it's just amazing uh it's an amazing
development i expect japan to approve it
i think it'll be great for the japanese
economy it's a great investment for mgm
and so when you look out over the next
so we're long-term investors so
it's 22 and i'm thinking about what 2030
is going to look like
uh mgm is going to be a substantially
bigger company yeah fascinating thesis
talking about bitcoin i know that uh
you've become uh pretty bullish on
bitcoin it seems at least from what i've
seen you say publicly i got a bitcoin
business all right explain uh one what
your thoughts are on bitcoin are and
then tell us about the bitcoin business
well you know
boy you know like look at what's
happening to our global system right
i mean we've weaponized the financial
system
you know so it's funny palm because i i
did this show with peter schiff the
other day
and boy was that frustrating you know
he
he's super annoying like he's really
really hard to like even have an
argument with because
he doesn't listen like he just doesn't
care what you say at all
and and it's super frustrating and you
know i was trying to explain you know
once again
the premise behind bitcoin
in that there should be a global
currency that isn't controlled by a
government and there's so many
instances even in the last year that i
can say where this utility has been
proven over and over and over again
right now if you're a russian you know i
have a friend who who lives in thailand
and he's like yeah all the russians
travel there and they've been stranded
you know like they're all stranded and
then their credit cards stopped working
so now they've all become like bitcoin
experts you know and then and everybody
you know in thailand you know has to
kind of get good at bitcoin because
all the tourists are now transacting in
bitcoin because their currencies are all
like banned or whatever
and so
when you start thinking about the way
governments have weaponized finance and
now what we're seeing with china
and you know
their goal to
you know we're moving we're
de-globalizing right now and that makes
bitcoin even more valuable as a global
currency you know
or a
system of finance that doesn't involve
governmental interaction and and so i
think the utility of bitcoin continues
to grow and what's happening now
what we're working on is we partnered
with gemiini and we are building managed
bitcoin accounts for clients so that
they can build portfolios with digital
assets just like they're building them
in traditional assets and our work with
gemiini has led me to believe kind of
like when i'm talking about tesla i
don't know if this is a fact but it's
led me to believe that soon companies
like gemini will be able to offer all
types of securities including stocks and
bonds in a digital wallet
by tokenizing all assets and maybe we'll
be able to manage
like
people's collectibles their real estate
like all their assets in theory in a
digital wallet with gemini so we're
working with them to build that right
now and we've been slowly because it's
been
you know a very manual process of
building
um
what i will consider the most advanced
most amazing
managed bitcoin system for people who
are not sophisticated enough to do it on
their own
and when you think about this uh most
clients this is like one two percent
this is like 10
but what what is most of the clients
that you're talking to about bitcoin how
are they thinking about this no 100 of
clients today are interested in bitcoin
they want to know more about it there's
a huge knowledge gap that's an area that
we're working on you know like tech
people have a really hard time
understanding humans that aren't tech
people you know and and that was kind of
like steve jobs brilliance and that's
what kind of bitcoin needs is that
person maybe it's me who can sort of
explain it to the regular person in a
way that they understand it
and doesn't scare them away
and i think that's being done more by
all these youtubers and bloggers who are
really bringing the message out in
different ways to different people
especially underserved groups like the
african-american community which
has really bought into bitcoin you know
like and i think it's a wonderful thing
you know because it's a community that's
been inherently discriminated against by
the banking system so we have this
enormous opportunity but we have to
educate people on how it works and
that's why the nft thing pisses me off
you know
it's like every time people get ripped
off and every time people lose money it
just hurts the credibility of the system
that we're building
yeah i tend to think that that is uh
exactly what's happening uh when you
start to think about bitcoin for clients
you said they're all interested in it
but there's a knowledge gap how many of
them are looking at it because it's an
inflation hedge or they're looking at it
because they think they can get rich
quickly like what's the driver that is
really pushing that interest
well always money you know greed is
always the first driver of everything
you know not that that's bad you know
it's kind of like porn is always the
first driver of internet you know
uh innovation but like
i think
we all understand
the limitations of
like wells fargo and jp morgan
controlling our financial system
they have abused our system for
i don't know as long as they've existed
and people don't earn any money in the
bank so the fed's going to raise you
know interest rates 50 basis points
they're not going to pay you 50 basis
points in your bank
right
so like wells fargo is going to like
raise their interest rate by 50 basis
points today so how is that fair
like what kind of system is that so
people don't want to hold their money in
the bank we've been preaching this since
i started in the business don't hold any
money in the bank why would you want to
hold money in a bank they pay you
nothing and they invest it and you have
all the risk of the bank why would you
have money in the bank so people are
saying like why would i keep money in
the bank i can keep my money in crypto
and that and it becomes a store of value
and people are like i'll just keep my
money in crypto and that's what i've
done with my own money it's like why
would i keep my money in the bank they
don't pay me interest on it i can put it
in ethereum i can put it in bitcoin and
and you know over time it'll probably go
up in value
i mean that makes uh makes a ton of
sense uh and i think that there's a lot
of people who as they learn more about
it they start to say to themselves wow i
didn't understand this i closed that
education gap
maybe i'm educated enough and feel
confident enough to store it myself
maybe i need help with it but it does
feel like uh there's a ton of people and
one of the metrics that i always look at
is uh the num the amount of bitcoin that
hasn't moved in the last year the higher
that percentage goes up the more that
just signals to me people are
understanding this idea of bitcoin as
savings technology yeah buy and hold
yeah we buy and hold it we we don't
trade it for clients yep like we're not
like trying to outsmart the bitcoin
market you know what i mean like it's at
let's say 38 000 today so we buy more
today you know like we just buy bitcoin
just like we buy tesla or we buy any
stock
see bitcoins easy in that there's a
limited supply
so it's a store of value just based off
supply and demand just like gold and you
know since gold really hasn't performed
as it traditionally has
one of the reasons i suspect is a lot of
that money has gone to bitcoin that
would traditionally have gone to gold i
don't know if that's true or not but i
suspect that may be true because gold
should be soaring in this environment
right and it really it's been a piece of
crap investment so
so what what what's going on with gold
do you think gold would be doing really
well right now actually
right
all the same elements that make bitcoin
interesting make gold interesting yet
gold hasn't performed so i think
investors are starting to look for the
digital version of these things and
that's bitcoin but there's a utility
with bitcoin you know like i used the
lightning network for the first time the
other day and boy that worked pretty
well and
all of a sudden like on the cash app i
did a couple transactions in bitcoin and
it was like wow this works pretty well
and actually bitcoin has been the most
solid currency in the world besides the
dollar
you know over the last six months
probably right look at the ruble or the
turkish lira or or a lot of currencies
they've been like going crazy and people
are like oh bitcoin's so volatile and
i'm like really
i mean that is the way to look at it
right is that uh it's all relative
volatility is relative and also evolving
oh sorry because as to say like china is
not going to want the dollar to be the
reserve currency anymore for sure and
and individuals are are kind of saying i
don't want
the one or i don't want the dollar i
don't want the ruble i don't want the
euro
and all for good reason right
and and what's left is is bitcoin
yeah it makes uh makes complete sense
ross i can talk to you forever my friend
where uh where can we send people to
find you on the internet or uh or find
more about what you guys are doing over
at gerber kawasaki well you can always
go to our website gerberkawasaki.com of
course we help people manage their money
the stocks bonds crypto and such
we're probably the only firm that
actually is integrated to all assets
digital and
physical i guess other than physical
real estate and then at gerberkalasaki
on twitter you can always follow me on
twitter um that's i do put out a lot a
lot of stuff on twitter um or on our
youtube page at youtube
gerber kawasaki but uh please follow
along um you know i'm a big believer in
young people investing in the future and
the amazing technologies like i'm really
really bullish on the future i i feel
lonely now because everybody's so
bearish but i'm like look at what's
being invented in america like we're
bringing business back to america with
all this great innovations happening in
america happening in europe and there's
so much utility to things that we're
building whether it be this global
financial system or like starlink and
the utility of a global internet system
think about how great starlink is for
bitcoin because i can't transact bitcoin
in the middle of nowhere if there's no
internet connection so all of a sudden
now i got starling terminals now i got
bitcoin globally even in antarctica so
you know now i got this global financial
system that's irrelevant of a government
now i got this global internet system
right that's irrelevant of a government
like wow there's some really cool things
happening
i love it i always love following you
pop and i love what you're doing and the
content you're putting out and and uh so
keep it up man i appreciate it very much
before i let you go uh one of our
sponsors is eight sleep what's your
sleep schedule you told me that you used
to not get that much sleep you getting
better sleep now
i always sleep pretty good i i'm my
seven hour guy and you know cannabis
cannabis cannabis in seven hours and
you're good to go you got all the energy
yeah cannabis before the seven
i love it all right i appreciate you
coming on we uh we definitely gotta get
you back uh soon and uh let's see what
uh what tesla and bitcoin end up doing
yeah you're carrying the torch my friend
we'll talk to you later
thank you all right bye